um
welcome to this
first
class session on lighthall this is
a
new platform for online learning it
looks very robust and i was invited to
take part in the the beta and what's
really cool about lighthall is
they specialize in live interactive
sessions with the idea as the the you
know ceo of it explained to me that
there's something that people really
enjoy about getting to interact with
somebody and getting to interact with
each other in the chat
so i think i'll probably be working with
this quite a bit in the future those of
you i think everybody probably knows me
but maybe not everybody knows
um all the different parts of
what i do i'm i'm the editor of stoicism
today i'm also the president of my own
company reason io i teach at milwaukee
institute of art and design i'm the
co-host of the wisdom for life radio
show and i you know as many of you know
i think i do a lot of
video production and other things as
well and so light uh lighthall reached
out to me and i think it's mainly on on
account of the youtube channel they said
would you like to
try out our our new platform and they
walked me through some of the
features of it and i thought well this
looks really good this this looks like
it has some real promise this is a lot
like youtube live except as i think some
of you are seeing it's got a lot more
cool features and so i i really kind of
like this um so i thought well what
should i do a class session on and i
thought well you know stoicism is
something that a lot of people
are very interested in now so we'll
focus on stoic philosophy
and practice and then zeroing in i
decided to focus on my favorite stoic
author who is epictetus
he's long been my favorite stoic author
and even though i really do like seneca
and other people i think you know
epictetus kind of holds constant in that
and then i thought um i'll zero in even
more on one particular work of epictetus
you know we have the longer discourses
and then we have the shorter end
caridian or handbook so i thought well
we'll do that
and then i thought well we need to zero
in even more you know we're not going to
cover the whole n caridian
so let's focus on five basic stoic
practices that epictetus
talks about not necessarily naming in
the same way that we're naming them here
but he talks about
in that um that text the end caridian so
um
[Music]
i decided i would pick five that i
myself find very useful in my own life
and and work
and actually andy is on the call with me
here she's my wife and partner and she
finds these useful because we have you
know we use a lot of these things to
negotiate the um the fact of being two
pretty type a people who live and work
and love together so i think these can
be very useful for for all of you um and
so the first one is the dichotomy of
control
the second one is depersonalizing
problems the third is paying
tranquility's price the fourth is
valuing your will or pro-euresis and
then the fifth is picking up the right
handle
you know why five why not just three or
just one or why not more i think that
five is a good number for a class like
this we have about 90 minutes
and so i think we can cover all of these
pretty well and address any confusions
or questions or stuff like that and i do
want to say something right off the bat
you shouldn't feel yourself under
pressure to like internalize all five of
these and come away from this you know
ready to
ready to rock so to speak um you know if
if you only get uh three of them that's
that's fine you know that still makes a
difference these are things that can be
not just you know intellectually
interesting but they make a difference
in your life and so even if you walk
away from this with just one that you
can use to develop a bit more resiliency
and you know orientation towards
happiness and calm and tranquility in
your life i think that's that's an
achievement so that's really quite
helpful the other thing i do want to
point out
so in the handout that i gave you on the
passages i'm i'm going to be referencing
one particular translation of epictetus
and i'm not doing that because i'm
endorsing it as like the better one i'm
just doing it out of a let's just say
laziness i i use the old father
translation because it's there in my
loeb edition as the english on the
facing page of the greek and i think
it's not a bad translation so
you know
you could you could find other
translations of these passages i'm just
providing you with the old father one
there
so um i do also want to say something
about philosophical
practices um
that's a term that we're using here
you'll also in the literature like if
you study pure ado
he calls them spiritual exercises michel
foucault calls them technologies of the
self but they're all basically the same
thing you're taking some ideas and then
you're actually doing something with
them in in the course of your life
you're practicing
so we don't have to get too hung up on
the terminology itself i do also want to
say that you know ado is not the only
person of course who who talks about
this concept of philosophy as a way of
life
there's many many others i've written
about this elsewhere
but it is a nice catchphrase
uh philosophy is a way of life uses
philosophical practices but there's more
than just philosophical processes and
likewise there's stoicism than just
these
practices that we're going to be
looking at another thing to say about
these is these are not you know simple
learn it once and you've got it down
kind of cookie cutter
life hacks right each of these that
we're going to look at
is something that as you work with you
you get better
and better at it and with it and you're
getting better and better at it and
sometimes failing
you come to understand it more fully so
it's not like you know learn it
apply it you know that if there's a
dialectic back and forth with the more
that you apply
them and reflect on you know we may have
some people here who've been you know
using these stoic practices for for many
years
you you learn more about them you
acquire
more insights about them and about
yourself
and typically are going to
have um sort of interconnected
cognitive that's thought right affective
that's mood or emotion
choice and act action dimensions or
components to them
so with each of these five exercises
we're going to look at the relevant
passage or passages from the end
caridian and then we'll discuss some of
the the basic concepts or ideas that are
involved in the practice
i'll point out ways that beginners can
get mixed up about this i'm not assuming
that everybody here is a beginner but
you know i'm assuming that some people
are and so there's there's ways in which
sometimes
lead people off track
we'll look at some examples that
epictetus himself provides in the end
caribbean one of the cool things about
each of these practices is it's not just
in that one chapter where he talks about
it
it's also discussed in other places
and then we'll look at some contemporary
examples i've got some for you i'm sure
that some of you will come up with some
examples as well and i was thinking that
after each of these
practices
we'll
take a little pause for q a for any
questions that come up or you know am i
doing this right or that sort of thing
and we'll also i think have time for
more general q a and discussion after we
go through all of these because i've
budgeted 90 minutes i think that should
probably be enough that's one of the
things though with live classes you
never quite know right um whether
there's great how long things are going
to take or how much
time you're gonna spend on each thing
that's a little bit of the the charm of
it i suppose right so
let's talk about the practice this is
one that i think a lot of people are
very familiar with and they're familiar
with it under this name the dichotomy of
control if you've read william irvine's
book
you know he proposes a trichotomy of
control or you know we can talk about
that if people are really interested in
that but i don't think that's um
particularly
necessary here so what is the relevant
passage it's at the very beginning of
the end caribbean
we should keep in mind too that
epictetus
he's he's the one who said the things in
the end caribbean but he's not the
person who wrote them down or who
arranged it so it's it's his his student
aryan who thought that this was you know
really the most important thing to start
with and it runs like this some things
are under our control while other things
are not under our control under our
control our conception
choice desire aversion
and in a word everything that is our own
doing not under our control are our body
our property reputation office
and in a word everything that is not our
own doing
remember therefore that if what is
naturally slavish you think to be free
and what is not your own to be your own
you will be hampered
will grieve we'll be in turmoil and will
blame both gods and men
well if you think only what is your own
to be your own and what
to be
is not your own then no one will be able
to exert compulsion upon you no one will
hinder you no one will blame you will
blame no one will find fault with no one
will do absolutely nothing against your
will you will have no personal enemy no
one will harm you for neither is there
any harm that can touch you
okay so those are some big promises
right but he is laying out for us a very
important distinction and a very
helpful
thing that we can do and that's that's
the philosophical practice you could say
there's a concept or you know very
important distinction and then there's
what you're actually
doing with it
now here is where
it is helpful to you know talk a little
bit about terminology
so the distinction in the greek is not
between what is in our control and what
is not in our control that's a way of
translating it another way of
translating it is
in our power not in our power sometimes
people get very focused on well you know
what what exactly counts as power what
counts as control
and that's kind of losing the thread
because literally it means what is
what is up to us
what is
our business is another way of
translating it what is
something that falls within our
purview
and so there's a distinction between all
these things that are
external including our body and we're
gonna we're gonna talk about that in a
bit
and then all these things that are
internal to
us
one set we we have control over or we
get to decide or we're determinative
right and the other stuff we can have
some input into it but ultimately
somebody or some something else is
calling the shots something else is
determining what happens
so this is a really important
distinction and it is important to point
out that epictetus thinks that we do
have some input and we can exercise you
know prudence or courage or whatever
in relation to those external things
like reputation you know online
reputation would be something epictetus
hasn't thought of but could matter to us
quite a bit property right the things
that we we own or income streams or
whatever
and um
notice what is in our control that he's
not naming here but as if you read
between the lines
it is in our control whether or not we
have a right understanding of this
distinction and about things
if we
think that things are outside of our
control are really you know up to us
that's a choice on our part that we
don't have to
make it is in what we do with this
distinction whether we focus on the
things in our control directing
our desires versions towards those like
deciding i want to be a better person
that's in your control according to
epictetus everybody else liking you not
in your control right so if you redirect
your desire or your aversions
towards what you actually do have
control over you're going to be as he
says
you're going to be
free you're going to be nobody's going
to get in your way you know
and so one key addition you know we
don't control all the results or
outcomes even if we have the best
intentions even if we
plan you know as much as we can
we don't control all the factors but we
do control
what we
decide to do in terms of responses
and how we we use things so
you know your body not totally in your
control as a matter of fact great
example you know having covid just you
know uh
a week and a half ago i think i tested
negative um you know when i took the
test i don't control i can i control
whether i do the test but i don't
control what the results are you know
it's the things that are going on in my
body that that uh determine that right
now how do beginners get mixed up about
this this is this is very common by the
way so if you do get mixed up about this
you don't have to feel bad about that
you just want to sort of like you know
figure out how you're going to
do better with it
the biggest way i would say
is
[Music]
mistaking
being things being up to us with
something that we have total control
over
in every aspect
so the fact that i do control for
example desire and aversion how i direct
those doesn't mean that i don't already
come into the world with desires and
aversions and that i haven't developed
them over time and that changing habits
may take a while for me you know so
um
that's that's one key thing to focus on
another big mistake that i see people
making
is um focusing totally on this passage
and then ignoring all the other things
that epictetus says elsewhere
about what's in our power what's in our
control and what's not in our control
including in the end caridian but in the
discourses
and then you know quibbling about
counter examples you know for example
you could say well i don't control my
thoughts i have uh intrusive thoughts
you know i have obsessive thoughts that
that affect me or i i have feelings that
i can't control well epictetus would say
okay
granted
what do you control about that
let's say that you suffer from
depression as i do i i'm diagnosed with
mild to moderate depression i've dealt
with it for
uh well since my teens
um let's say you start feeling negative
you know
mood and you start engaging in what we
call negative self-talk
um
you you may have intrusive thoughts you
may have you know a down mood you decide
what you're going to do with that i mean
you can't like snap your fingers and
suddenly everything is okay
but
you do still have some measure of
control and you can focus on what you
actually do have some some measure of
control
over right
so let's look at some examples and then
there's there's some good questions here
already
epictetus says in chapter 24
let not these reflections oppress you i
shall live without honor and be nobody
anywhere and then he says it's not your
business is it to get office or to be
invited to a dinner party certainly not
and how is it you will be nobody
anywhere when you ought to be somebody
only in those things which are under
your control wherein you are privileged
to be a person of the very greatest
honor but your friends will be without
assistance what do you mean by being
without assistance they will not have
some coin from you you won't make them
roman citizens well who told you that
these are some of the matters under our
control and not rather things that
others do so what do we see here we see
him applying
this very distinction
in a way talking to somebody else and
saying listen buddy the things that
you're worried about these are not
things that are actually under your
control so you shouldn't be
too focused on those
another good example is in chapter 31
where he says
the result that you're looking for
cannot be secured in any other way than
by withdrawing your idea of the good and
the evil from the things that are not
under our control
and placing it in those things that are
under our control and in these alone if
you think any of those those things that
are not under our control are good or
evil then when you fail to get what you
want and fall into what you don't want
it's all together inevitable you're
going to blame and hate those who are
responsible for these results but you
actually have control
over whether you observe this
distinction or not
and then in chapter 50 he says pay no
attention to what somebody says about
you this is very difficult to do of
course but
why should you not pay attention to what
people are saying about you he says
this isn't under your control
so you don't have to
allow that to
get to you and i did want to use as a
contemporary example the body right so
one of the objections that my students
always have when we go over this passage
as they say well wait a second
i do have control over my body you know
i choose what i eat i choose whether
exercise i choose whether i clean it up
or not like take showers i choose
whether i sleep the right amount i
choose the amount of
stress i i put myself under in some
cases
you know what does epictetus mean saying
that i don't control my body at all
and
you know i can to say of course and he's
got all sorts of exercise metaphors in
in his works
um
you can choose to exercise but there are
going to be some things that you don't
really have much control over i mean as
a 51 year old man
i
lift weights in part because i want to
keep my bones from getting brittle
and i want to you know
remain strong and healthy
into my old age
but i don't have control over that i
don't have 100 control i mean i could
well look at this you know i got covered
whether i exercise or not right um i
could walk out from the gym and and boom
there there comes the bus and it hits me
and i'm dead right our bodies are things
that we we should take care of but we
don't have perfect control over we
control what we do with it to some
degree but we don't control all the
outcomes you know
you could say that we have partial
control if you want to and this is where
you know the the notion of that
trichotomy of control comes in and the
hand the uh worksheet that i i provided
you with that that you know you may find
useful for that
um it's interesting too i'll point out
and then i do want to answer this this
question
the systems out there that
are are trying to sell us things to make
our bodies better oh you need to take
these pills oh you got to go on to you
know nutrisystem to lose weight oh you
got to do this you got to do that oh go
to the gym and do this kind of exercise
what are they really promising us
they're promising us that if we do
something
we are
going to have greater control than we
actually can have
and a lot of people will pay lots and
lots of money and spend lots and lots of
time and devote a lot of desire and
aversion and their feelings
to things that they don't ultimately
have
control over being realistic about these
things is incredibly
liberating
all right so let's let's take some of
the questions so everett has uh two
questions here
do you think a person with dementia
alzheimer's has internals that they
control yeah i mean until they're like
completely gone from that yes but it's a
much
uh narrower
um
you know set of things that they have
control over
um and that's one of the things that
really sucks about seeing somebody going
through alzheimer's you know and in the
early stages too where people realize
that they're starting to forget they're
starting to slip they often get very
angry
at other people and at themselves
because they feel like they ought to
have
all of their faculties with them right i
saw my grandfather go through this and
my great-aunt
go through this
and many of us have seen other people go
through it as well
um you know
we we don't know to say that we have
control doesn't mean that we have like
perfect absolute control none of us none
of us have that
um
everett also says would you repeat how
you can respond stoically to negative
self-talk well i didn't actually say how
you can respond to it i just said that
you can indeed respond to it
and and one thing is it's not
particularly stoic i mean cbt teaches
you this and so does so many other
things you can respond to your negative
self-talk by saying
this is not uh
the reality of things just because my
negative self-talk is telling me that
you know if my negative self-talk is
telling me
don't apply for this job because you
have no chance of getting it or that
person is never going to care about you
or you're ugly or pick whatever else you
like right
you know i've got my chalkboard right
you suck as a professor
um
you you can say to yourself and you know
you can do this in a stoic way by using
epictetus and some of the things that he
says
why are you buying into
that
appearance that fontasia in the greek
that impression is another way of
translating it so that's that's one way
um
andrew says can't get my head around
money is indifferent i can't stop
thinking about my income which is low i
can rationally see how it's an
indifferent how can i accept it
by um going further with the indifferent
and realizing that the stoics don't say
that you should be indifferent to
everything that's indifferent right
that's a mistake there are favored or
preferred indifference and then there
are disfavored or rejected indifference
this is a very big
issue by the way which i'm going to not
fully address here because i've talked
about this quite a bit in other places
you can just you know google
gregory sadler stoic indifference and
you'll see several talks that i've given
where i talk specifically about you know
money and
things like that but you know the key is
to
you know slowly move your desires and
aversions
uh away from from focusing so much on on
externals or indifference right and it's
not to say that again you flip a light
switch and suddenly all of this happens
this is something that requires going at
it over and over again but
this is a distinction and this is a
practice
that you can
apply and it will it will certainly make
you better off in in doing so
let's go on to the to the next one um
depersonalizing
problems so this one comes from later on
in the end caribbean and epictetus says
what the will of nature is may be
learned from a consideration of the
points in which we do not differ
from one another
for example when some person's slave boy
breaks his drinking cup you are
instantly ready to say and how many of
us can relate to us not slaves but uh
you know saying this to other people
that's one of the things that happened
rest assured then when your own drinking
cup gets broken
you ought to behave in the same way that
you do when the other man's cup is
broken
apply now the same principle to matters
of greater importance some other
person's child or wife has died no one
would but would say such as the fate of
man yet when a man's own child dies
immediately the cry is woe is me but we
ought to remember how we feel when we
hear of the same misfortune
falling
befalling others
and so what are the basic concepts
involved here
well you know we tend to think that or
feel that our own case is somehow
different
or
special or exceptional
you know whatever happens to me is
somehow worse than what other people
are going through and we can remind
ourselves that's a massive assumption
on our part it's a natural one because
you know we spend all our time with
ourselves right we do care about what
happens to ourselves
but
we're just one of many many beings
in in the world today and throughout all
of history
and you know we're all special in our
own way but we're not like unique
exceptions to the nature of human beings
so you know
what is he telling us to do here remind
ourselves about how we look at these
things when it's other people
experiencing or suffering these things
so if you know when when something bad
happens to somebody else
we sometimes laugh at it
maybe we should apply that to ourselves
or you know more uh
we could say sympathetically you know
when we see somebody lose their job and
we're like well i'm sure they'll find a
way to manage
um why don't we say that about ourselves
maybe we can or think about bad breakups
another great example if you've ever had
a friend and you consoled them by saying
well there's many fish in the ocean you
know and then they're like well i only
want that one fish oh you know if if you
think that um
[Music]
the logic applied to them it also
applied to
to you
and we can ask ourselves we can distance
ourselves from our own you know
immediate feelings and thoughts we can
say well how does my situation look from
another person's point of view
you know
um and you know we can also by doing
this over time we can start taking some
confidence in our own possibilities for
responding in better and more reasonable
more free ways right that aren't going
to
make us feel quite so so bad
now there are there are ways that people
get mixed up about this
so you know beginners will sometimes
think about this in an immediate way and
maybe
um
overdo it right they think well if
somebody else can deal with this well
i can deal with it well right so if my
sibling my friend my co-worker dealt
with this thing what's wrong with me
that i can't you know buck up and and
deal with it and what we should do in
those cases is think about
am i not an exceptional case but what is
it in me that makes me
more susceptible
to feeling bad feeling down about this
particular kind of thing let's take
romantic relationships you know if
you've been hurt a lot in the past and
your friend who you're looking at who
seems to like you know go from a
relationship to relationship without
getting hurt um you know has a breakup
and you're like well i should be like
them when somebody breaks up with me
you might not be ready to do that until
you figure out why
you
you know get get over invested in people
who aren't right for you or something
like that
another thing that beginners do too is
they look at unrealistic stories
about what so and so is capable of
and then they say well if they can do it
i can do it right and they forget the
fact that stories are often you know
made up or
left out all the
parts that are really important so you
know if if this celebrity can handle
this situation given all the the stuff
that they've got
all the resources available to them well
i should be able to handle it well no
that's a mistake because you're not in
exactly the same situation as they are
right and we probably also don't want to
take people who are just simply
apathetic or disengaged you know as as
good models for what we're
capable of
um we want to look at at other people
so let's look at some of the examples
that epictetus uses
in chapter five he talks about death
he says
it's not the things themselves that
disturb people but their judgments about
these things you've all probably heard
this passage
for example
death is nothing dreadful or else
socrates too would have thought so but
the judgment that death is dreadful this
is the dreadful thing
so whenever we're hindered or disturbed
or grieved let's not blame anyone but
ourselves that means our own judgments
we blame our own assumptions or
viewpoints about these these sorts of
things okay so
socrates
wasn't
worried about dying and if you want to
know why you can you know read plato's
apology which you know provides some
some of the arguments that socrates uses
likewise xenophon's apology does as well
um
and there's something to that
you know we can say
it's not necessary
that we
are
worried about death
but that doesn't mean again that we can
just like flip a switch and suddenly not
be worried about it because socratesism
we need to figure out why we're worried
about it why we're bothered about it
another thing that involves socrates is
in chapter 33 says when you're about to
meet somebody in particular when it is
one of those people who are held in very
high esteem propose to yourself the
question what would socrates or zeno
have done under these circumstances then
you won't be at a loss to make proper
use of the occasion and you know part of
it would be socrates or xeno wouldn't be
like intimidated by them
uh they wouldn't be you know kissing
their butt or anything like that we'll
talk about that a little bit
later and so if that's a possibility for
them you know we can we can
de-personalize it and say well that's
that's also
a possibility for me but we don't have
to go to socrates or zeno we could think
about people much closer to us in time
and space who we particularly
respect or think you know have have
things put together
chapter 16
when you see someone weeping in sorrow
either because a child has gone on a
journey or because he's lost his
property beware that you not be carried
away by the impression that the person
is in the midst of external ills but
keep before you this thought it's not
what has happened that distresses this
person because it doesn't distress
another
but his judgment about it don't hesitate
to sympathize with him as far as words
go and if occasion offers even to groan
with him but don't groan in the center
of your being what is this saying
again this is saying
you can apply that same logic to other
people
you can say well you know they don't
necessarily have to be as negatively
affected by things because look at other
people are able to
handle that
but you know that doesn't mean that you
don't sympathize with them you can still
go and say oh yeah it sucks that you you
went through this breakup or you lost
your job or
you know your
your uh child has gone on a journey or
you've lost your property or stuff like
that
um
you know so some contemporary examples
of this that i think could be useful for
us you know another indifferent or
external um
reputation or social status
when when we feel ourselves to be
slighted or put down or humiliated
publicly
we view it as an attack on ourselves and
you know we can get very upset about
that and we can look at other people who
were you know in similar circumstances
and we can say to ourselves well
i don't have to be
as upset about this or maybe i don't
even need to be upset about this period
that is a possibility for me it doesn't
mean that it automatically you know
makes us feel better but we can say yeah
this is a possibility
for me and that's very liberating as
well the notion that we we can do this
we can also apply this to our own
getting upset about other people
not being upset you know when we say how
can people you know not be worked up
about the fact that the government is
doing this or the people that we're
opposed to politically are doing this
well
you know
is that a necessary thing that we get
angry and irritated and you know
uh
post mean things on on this social media
or that social media
no because if socrates was around in the
present or epictetus was around in the
present they wouldn't have to do that
right
so
we can apply that to our ourselves and i
think we can think of many other
examples where we can
de-personalize these problems it doesn't
mean that we we become you know
de-personalized ourselves it means that
we adopt a wider
point of view and we say
that doesn't have to get to me the way
that i'm allowing it to get to me so
um let's take a little pause here any
questions
um cases comments people want to make
about this this second one
of de-personalizing our our problems
that we have
all right so there's quite a few here uh
nancy
um okay this is a good point i i i like
this another approach switch on your
curiosity mode and ask yourself i wonder
why this happened yeah
and you can do that with the outside
things right i wonder why
this person said the jackass thing they
said and epictetus tells you the answer
that because they thought that was a
good thing to do they may be mistaken
about that right but people are
generally following what they ought to
do
um wellbeing says how do you apply this
to stuff like child molestation i know
extreme examples
would it be appropriate to apply that
you know
as the victim to say oh well i shouldn't
be bothered because i mean do we know
that socrates wouldn't be bothered by
child
molestation uh you know that's that's a
that's a big assumption there and you
know one thing i do want to point out so
there's a larger thing here the the
stoics sometimes are interpreted as
saying you should put up with whatever
abuse
people give you because it's really all
in your head they're not saying that
they're not saying that at all as a
matter of fact epictetus
will
um as we're going to look at a little
bit later when he's talking about your
brother being mean to you actually being
unjust to you he doesn't deny that
there's an injustice going on there or
wrong and we can talk about some very
very deep wrongs torture child
molestation
you know the kind of exploitation that
destroys entire communities right
stoics think that justice is a virtue
and that injustice is a vice and if you
look at what the stoics did in their
lives they had no problem criticizing
people for injustice and saying it was
wrong or even going to war over it like
like cato did against
caesar
um
so
you know
depersonalizing it you could say well
what do i think about other people
being molested do i do i say uh that
just it's just what happens or do i say
oh this is really bad
but it doesn't have to destroy my life
it doesn't have to place me on a
you could say path of replication of
trauma i mean this is one of the
problems that happens with people who
are abused right they become quite
fearful of themselves becoming abusers
you can you can look at
by de-personalizing this you can say
well that doesn't have to be a
possibility for me but what do i need to
do
in order for this not to
to um
[Music]
to continue right
michael says when you feel attacked or
insulted you should examine the
statement for a grain of truth
yeah i mean
examine it for a grain of truth there
may not always be a grain of truth there
some people are just mean jerks
it has nothing to do with you uh they're
just belligerent but yeah sometimes uh
you know especially when you when you
feel yourself attacked but the other
person says they're not attacking you
there might be something there to worry
about
marco says is it okay to ask questions
seemingly off topic but what are
connected to stoicism in general i would
say those to the end we're going to like
take little q a's for each of the
practices and then i think we should
have plenty of time
left by the end to do more general stoic
questions
so let's move on to the next one paying
tranquility's price now this is my own
terminology for it
this is not something that i think a lot
of other people call it but it it it
makes sense to call it this so here's
the passage from the uncaridian
if you want to make progress
dismiss all reasoning of this sort if i
neglect my affairs i shall have nothing
to live on if i do not punish my slave
boy he will turn out bad for it's better
to die of hunger but in a state of
freedom from grief and fear
than to live in plenty but troubled in
mind and if it is better for your slave
boy to be bad then for you to be unhappy
now here's the practice begin therefore
with the little things your paltry oil
gets spilled your miserable wine stolen
say to yourself this is the price paid
for a calm spirit this is the price for
peace of mind nothing
is gotten without a price
so when you call your slave boy bear in
mind it's possible he may not heed you
and again that even if he does heed he
may not do what you want done but he is
not so happy a condition that your peace
of mind depends on him now
[Music]
i want to point something out
most of us don't have servants thank
thank goodness i think we live in a more
egalitarian society these days
but what could you substitute for this
this
your technology right aristotle actually
talks in politics book one where he he's
discussing slavery about the possibility
of like you know looms uh and shuttles
moving themselves and he says well that
happens we don't need slaves for
anything you know we can just let the
technology do it we live in a time where
we get we get quite upset with our
technology for not doing exactly what
it's expected to do right um you know we
i i've got siri series actually not all
that that smart uh doesn't give you the
right answers all the time i you know
the the bit the amp that i usually get
most bothered by
is the maps app because it will
give you bad routes right
uh because michael has a good point here
substitute children for slaves not to
use them as but in not letting them take
your tranquility yeah i mean we could
talk about co-workers we could talk
about uh the printer we could talk about
you know you take a sip of water oh that
doesn't taste good right um
we've got all these things that could be
aggravations for us they could be
instances where we get upset about
something
and um
[Music]
i i don't think that
um
we're ever going to run out of examples
that we could use for this
what we do is we keep in mind okay i i
pay a price for what it is that i want
what are my priorities so here's a basic
concept
everything has its price and they're not
all settled once and for all in advance
we're the ones who get to decide what
we're willing to pay in exchange for
what and a lot of times we make dumb
pricing decisions and we come to
stoicism having made a whole lifetime of
dumb pricing decisions in part because
other people have been telling us stupid
things about how things you know ought
to be exchanged for each other right so
what we have to do
is and here's the practice
we have to determine
what our priorities are and then we have
to stick with it we have to remind
ourselves when things are irritating
uh you know you get on the highway and
you ever have this ex you know those of
you who drive you get on the highway and
you're going up the the on-ramp and you
get there and it's like bumper to bumper
traffic and you're like oh now i'm gonna
be late you know
and you don't know whether you're going
to be late maybe it eases up a little
bit later on maybe you're stuck in rush
hour for for two hours but you say well
not getting worked up about that that's
the price of tranquility
you know we don't have to
uh worry about that so much
now this doesn't mean that we have to
accept anything whatsoever
we are the ones who have been given the
choice
about how to prioritize things
and again it's not something you can
change automatically
but it is something that you can work on
over time beginners often get mixed up
about this
then there i have seen two main ways
that i see people doing this one is you
know looking at this is very cynical uh
and not cynical in the classic sense but
in the modern sense because of all the
all the talk about prices and paying and
saying well that doesn't have anything
to do with a noble character
no epictetus actually thinks that it is
something that's very very uh important
if you want to
enjoy a happy life a free life you have
to start looking at what you have been
you know charging things as
the other thing is um
focusing on the choices and deals that
other people are making before getting
some reasonable stability in your own
you know stoicism is very much
especially at the beginning
about the if you know this metaphor eyes
on your own paper
right you've got to instead of worrying
about what everybody else is doing um
you know and whether they're behaving in
a stoic way or not and what sort of you
know things they're valuing
look at your own life and figure out
whether you are allowing yourself to get
aggravated by by things or not so here's
a great example that epictetus provides
i love this one
um as does my wife because of i think
the the
culinary things has someone been honored
above you at a dinner party or in
salutation or in being called to give
advice
if these manners are these matters are
good you ought to be happy that they got
them but if they're bad don't be
distressed because you didn't get them
and bear in mind that if you don't act
the same way as others do
with a view to getting things that are
not under our control
you can't be considered worthy to
receive an equal share with others
how is it possible for a person who does
not haunt some man's door
to have equal shares with the man who
does
for the man who does not do escort duty
with the man who does for the man who
does not praise with the man who does
you will be unjust therefore and in
insatiable if while refusing to pay the
price for which such things are bought
you want to obtain them for nothing
what's the price for heads of lettuce an
oval perhaps if then somebody gives up
his oval and gets his heads of lettuce
well you don't give up your oval and
don't get them don't imagine you're
worse off than the man who gets his
lettuce for he has his heads of lettuce
and you have the oval which you've not
getting away you've not given away
it's the same way also in life you
haven't been invited to somebody's
dinner party of course not
you didn't give the host the price at
which he sells his dinner he sells it
for praise he sells it for personal
attention given the price then for which
it is sold if it is to your interest
but if you wish both not to give up the
one and to get the other you're
insatiable in a simpleton have you
nothing in place of dinner indeed you
have you've not
had to praise the man you did not want
to praise you've not had to put up with
the insolence of his doorkeepers i mean
if we want to be very crude about this
you could say
if you want to get things from certain
people you have to kiss their behinds
and if you're not willing to do that
because you you don't want to kiss
people's behinds well then don't get
worried about the fact that other people
have done that and they got those
benefits you know
we have to decide for ourselves what it
is that we we truly
value right
so uh you know some contemporary
examples um using online platforms and
technology you know they're constantly
being updated uh you know i remember
when facebook when i first got on it
when they went through their first
change of look and people were just
outraged oh my god i can't believe that
facebook did this to me and i'm gonna
quit and stuff like that
a lot of them didn't quit and and
everybody adapted to it eventually you
know what were they doing they were
letting something that
doesn't matter at all
get to them they were they were paying a
price there and throwing away any sort
of tranquility we get to decide
what we're cool with and what we're not
cool with and
you know
we do so within certain structures you
could say uh like he points out you know
if you don't pay for the lettuce you
don't get the lettuce but you're the one
who decides whether you pay for
the lettuce and so it's very important
to like look at what we're willing to
trade things for so let's take a couple
questions
james says you translated cacodymonia as
unhappy no i didn't old father did who's
the translator who i used could you say
something about a person's genius and
stoicism no i couldn't because that's
that's a totally different topic that's
doesn't really matter here
michael lord of the rings quote from
gandalf that applies to being late that
is stoic i'm neither early nor late i
arrived precisely when i intended to
you did but you did so we think about
prices at the price of missing part of
the
presentation fortunately it is being
recorded and you can watch it later so
you know that's good so gabor has a good
ques what if i'm so so much overwhelmed
already or so much stress that i cannot
control my answers to hard and stressful
situations i work a lot have small
children do go for run occasionally
it seems my reactions are out of control
most of the time i cannot stop
ruminating well
you can you can't change it all at once
you can decide which things you want to
work on and here's a point where
stoicism is in consonance with many of
the other
um you know we could call them
intentional ways of living or
philosophies of life you don't try to
boil the ocean you don't change
everything all at once
pick one thing that you want to work on
and then be forgiving with yourself for
the others
you know
to get outside of stoicism
i'll bring up somebody else who i do a
lot of work on and some of canterbury
anselm is talking about fasting which is
very very important for the monastic
life and he actually tells some monks in
his work the day simultaneous
don't fast
not that all monks shouldn't fast but
you buddy shouldn't fast because when
you do you get really irritable with all
your fellow monks and you're kind of an
a-hole why don't you work on that part
of yourself first then you can work on
the fasting and we can say the same
thing with ourselves you know so
if you have you know you know gabor
mentions working a lot having small
children
ruminating uh okay so those are three
different things
you probably
can work on one of those like being you
know um
being less irritated with with the
children i mean children are a lot of
work i mean when i have my kids
i'm much more worn out and they're
adults now well actually one of them is
an adult one is a teenager
i mean back when they were younger man
kids demand a lot of energy so maybe you
can only work on that part of your life
and and the other things have to
you know take a back seat and you have
to be a little bit forgiving with
yourself and say
i'm doing the best that i can but you're
still able to make some some progress
right uh atoll says is there such a
thing as a very good bargain
or unreasonable high price for these
sorts of things yes that that's a great
way to frame it
um the cool thing about again stoicism
or other intentional ways of living is
that there are
bargains that are being put on the table
for you
to be happy
you don't have to actually do that much
there are some things you have to like
be cool with giving up right
but
people have been making themselves happy
with this stuff for over 2000 years
so and it doesn't require having you
know a high
income or living in the right hood or
things like that so there are bargains
in this and from a stoic perspective
most people pay unreasonably high prices
for most things so that's that's kind of
a cool way to extend the metaphor
ricardo says what if i have ocd how can
i manage my logic skills if my mind is
playing with me well we talked about
this a little bit earlier right if you
have intrusive thoughts
you decide what you want to do with
those intrusive thoughts do you want to
listen to them are you purely their
victim or do you have some measure of
you know responsiveness and control and
the answer is yes you do nobody is
totally
you know like a robot
within the the
the determinism
of something else and so you know if you
have ocd you can like learn how to live
with it as so many other people do
or you can allow it to interfere with
all these other things and that that
does go to this price thing right
all of us have things we struggle with
you know i mentioned earlier that
i have struggled with depression since i
was a teenager i got into stoicism in
part to try to better understand and
deal with anger which i still have not
you know like conquered as the stoic
sage or something like that i still
struggle with we all have things that we
struggle with but
none of them are outside of our control
entirely where we're just victims of
them it's it a lot of the things do
require like this thing to be handled
and this thing to be handled and this
thing to be handled
and there are no you know shortcuts or
magic bullets
that deal with everything all at once
but it is possible through you know
working
with these practices and many others to
um
to do more and more right
all right let's move on to practice
number four
valuing your will or prior races
in chapter four
epictetus tells us
when you are on the point of putting
your hand to some undertaking remind
yourself of the nature what the nature
of that undertaking is
if you're going out of the house to
bathe put before your mind what happens
at a public bath those who are splashing
you with water who jostle you who vilify
you and rob you and thus you will go
about your undertaking more securely if
at the outset you say to yourself i want
to take a bath
and at the same time
keep my
uh moral purpose in harmony with nature
and do so in every undertaking
for thus if anything happens to hinder
you and your bathing you'll be ready to
say oh well well this is not the only
thing i wanted but i wanted also to keep
my moral purpose in harmony with nature
and i won't keep it if i'm vexed at what
is going on
so um
one really basic concept you notice that
there's this term moral purpose there
and you might be like what is that what
does it have to do with the will
the term that epictetus is using is
prohiracis
and this is
a term that's a little bit difficult to
translate
and you shouldn't try to find a single
perfect translation for it because there
isn't one
it gets translated as will
as faculty of choice moral purpose
there's a number of other
translations as well
the key thing is that it's our capacity
to choose
and it's also the core
of who we are
there's a significant overlap with what
the stoics call the ruling
faculty as well in fact some people
think it's exactly the same thing in
epictetus
so
whatever words you want to use for it
the the point is from a stoic
perspective you
as the person you are you have a measure
of capacity to choose for yourself
including choosing
how you use and understand
that very capacity
you notice that he also
talks about being in harmony with nature
and
what does he mean by this i mean that's
a much bigger topic that i again i've
talked about in other places you can
easily google it
marcos is faculty meaning something akin
to ability yeah if you want to use
ability but a faculty is like something
that you have and you keep it's not just
an ability that you have at one single
moment it's you could say capacity again
don't worry about terminology so much
here right
back to harmony with nature
for the stoics being in harmony or in
accordance with nature
means being in accordance with the way
the the universe the world works
including the you know the way things
are structured
but also
developed human nature not a screwed up
human nature but you know what human
nature is
capable of the stoics thought that we
are by nature
beings that are rational that have a
capacity to tell right from wrong not a
perfect one at the start but you know
some some degree of that
and we have a uh you know
social or political or however you want
to put a communal nature as well and so
you know
making your choices along those lines is
using your pro-irasis or your your
faculty of choice
and you have the choice of what it is
that you're going to focus on
that very choice
is how you use that choice
right
um you shape your pro-erasis by how you
use it and so this involves a lot of
prioritization so you notice that that
this involves a lot of the things we've
been talking about so far you choose
whether you pay attention to what's in
your control and what's not you choose
what prices you're going to pay right
you see how these start to come together
now
ways that beginners often get mixed up
about this is
sometimes making it way too abstract in
specific circumstances and it becomes
some something like you know a
conscience categorical imperative that's
not what epictetus is talking about
there's also a tendency to to forget the
fact that the pro-racist is something
dynamic
it's something that we have input into
something that changes over time right
so
it's not something that you have once
and for all
it's something that you you work on
using it to work on it right
and um
we can look at some of the examples that
epictetus provides
so in 38 he says just as you're careful
in walking about not to step on a nail
or sprain your ankle
be careful also not to hurt your
governing principle or your ruling
principle
if we observe this rule in every action
we will be more secure in setting about
it so when you're in a situation like
you know of course going to the greek
bath house no we go to the pool instead
right and somebody does something we
don't like i don't know they
they they pee in the pool right you say
well you know
i'm i can choose to be upset about that
you know or i can choose to keep my uh
prayer races in accordance with nature
that's up to me right somebody splashes
me or people are loud you know they're
playing music i don't like right uh or i
go to the restaurant and you know the
waiter takes too long and coming to me
what was i i obviously would like the
waiter to come on time but
which of these am i going to prefer it's
up to me i get to choose that you know
in uh chapter 13 he says if you wish to
make progress then be content to appear
senseless and foolish in externals do
not make it your wish to give the
appearance of knowing anything and if
some people think you to be an important
personage just trust yourself for be
assured it is no easy matter to keep
your moral purpose in a state of
conformity with nature and at the same
time to keep externals but the man who
devotes his attention to one of these
two things must inevitably neglect the
other so you know this is good to keep
in mind as well and you have the choice
between these which are you going to
focus on the third one that's really a
great passage is chapter nine
disease is an impediment to the body
but not to the moral purpose unless that
consents
lameness this is something epithetis
knew quite well
is an impediment to the leg but not to
the moral purpose
say this to yourself at each thing that
befalls you and you will find the thing
to be an impediment to something else
but not to yourself
notice the common aspect here in the
situations that you get into here's how
it's a practice
remind yourself that you have to choose
proirasis which is what i am and what i
bring to you know to every situation i'm
in and that i have some you know control
over
or other things which am i going to
place the focus on uh great example and
then we'll we'll take some of these um
some of these questions great example
that i can relate to that that we
actually encountered just a few weeks
actually just just before i got covered
going to a concert when you go to a
concert people are recording with their
phones you know you see all these
lights they go back and forth constantly
to get beers they're chatting with each
other we were at a concert the other day
and there were these people that other
people in the concert were like actually
saying hey can you shut up we're trying
to listen to this music here uh people
get up and dance you know and they're
dancing isn't very good
sometimes the musicians aren't you know
100 percent or the music isn't mixed
well or the lights don't work the way
they're supposed to be and you can you
can say well why did you buy these
tickets and make all the arrangements to
get to the concert did you do it because
you wanted to enjoy the show yeah but
you know sometimes
you have to decide
are you going to focus on these negative
aspects or are you going to
keep your priorities in accordance with
nature and you know it sounds a little
artificial
you know
you could maybe have like a little flash
card that you get out every once in a
while or put something on your phone
keep your priorities in accordance with
nature
after a while you start you get you get
better and better at it you get to
recognize oh this is a place where i can
i can decide between these things
all right so everett says in the case
the universe is deterministic is our
prior racist actually the ability to
respond to our deterministic universe
determinism comes in a lot of different
blends so that's sort of an abstract
idea the stoic idea there's freedom in
the universe and there's causal
determinism they're compatibilists right
and there's many different versions of
this and so the answer in a very trivial
way is
yes of course the prairie races is an
ability to respond to the deterministic
universe and so much other things like
the ability to
determine itself and determine whether
we understand ourselves and all these
other things as well
everett also says
is prairie racist the tool we use for
paying tranquility's price it is that's
a great question
you could look at it as a tool right but
it's more than a tool it is you
epictetus at one point in the discourses
says you are pro-racist
and your pro-racist determines
pro-racist it's so free
even god
zeus
can't like reach in there and and make
you do things a certain way
so it is um you could say that it is
connected with with
uh the prices and it is one of those
things
that we can decide we don't want to sell
you see so that's quite important
um
everett goes on to say you can only
choose you can only choose what and how
you react if you're relaxed enough if
you're out of your i mean this is a good
bore if you're out of your stress zone
you cannot it seems to me mindfulness is
the key to stoicism other this otherwise
the situation will trigger you that's
partly right partly wrong
uh from the stoic perspective you're
you're never like totally incapable
of um choosing some things right
it can be more or less difficult for you
you don't have to i mean mindfulness is
important the stoics actually call that
pro-soul attention and that's a big part
of basically all
philosophies as ways of life right
but you don't necessarily have to be
doing mindfulness practices to do that
and you can here's the cool thing you
can actually practice these things in
your stress zone right
you may not be able to do it right away
but eventually you can start doing these
things and your life gets better and
better and better the more that you can
get into your stress zone and you know
monkey around and and fix things
so marco has one of the keys here if one
is overcome by a strong passion you
should probably take a pause before
reacting and the stoics advocate that
and epictetus talks about that at a
number of places that's another one of
the stoic practices taking a pause and
that again plays a big role in
in other ways of doing it even plays a
role in science fiction you know in a
event votes uh you know uh novels he
calls this the phthalmic pause right you
you uh try to keep yourself from you
know immediately reacting from the uh
certain parts of your brain right so
yeah very important stuff
all right let's
let's look at the last uh practice
and this goes to a very famous quote and
i've given you a handout a worksheet for
this that may be useful
picking things up by the right handle
epictetus says and this is in chapter 43
of the end caribbean
everything has two handles by one of
which it ought to be carried
by the other knot
if your brother wrongs you
don't lay hold of the matter by the
handle of the wrong that he's doing
because this is the handle by which the
matter ought not to be carried but
rather by the other handle that he is
your brother that you were brought up
together and that you'll be laying hold
of the matter by the handle by which it
ought to be carried now easier said than
done of course right as is the case very
often
with uh these these matters
um
notice something very important here too
epictetus is not saying that the brother
is not doing anything wrong or that it's
all in your head
he says the brother does wrong the other
person this practice
doesn't mean that the wrong goes away or
that you ignore it or repress it right
those are
those are counterproductive approaches
to this what this does involve is the
use of the proir races
on things that are in our control what
we
want to focus on how we're framing
matters what values we want to
prioritize
those things are up to us and you know
it may be difficult right especially if
your brother's acting like a jerk to you
and they've been a jerk the entire time
you've known them or you're involved
with a romantic partner and you know
they turned out to be the wrong person
or you've got a irritating co-worker
boss or whoever right but
we do have some some measure of control
over this
we're framing the matters
so
we should think about what does this
mean to us whether something can be
carried or not whether we can deal with
it doesn't mean that we have to be like
totally happy about it
but can we can we deal with it and there
are ways of looking at things where we
can be sure we're not going to be able
to deal with it i'm a victim and i can
never do anything about my circumstances
that's not a handle by which you can
carry things around in your life
you're going to be miserable you know
beginners often get mixed up about this
thinking that it means that you have to
pretend everything is totally okay
that it demands like toxic positivity
that's not the case or enduring abuse
that sets up or triggers other problems
i mean this goes back to some of the
questions earlier and i do want to
reiterate that stoicism doesn't demand
of you that if you're in a abusive
relationship that you just suck it up
and take it
that is not what you have to do
as a matter of fact you could look at
yourself and say well i matter too i
don't need to put up with this sort of
thing and especially if there's others
involved like you know say children you
can say well i don't want that for my
kids either you know
another way that beginners often get
mixed up about this
is being too prone
to apply this to other people to say
you need to pick things up by the right
handle look on the bright side you know
the stoics say you can deal with it no
no you
again stoicism is about
focusing on your own page right work on
your own work before you start worrying
about whether other people are measuring
up to a philosophy that you're
interested in that they may not even
care about right
so um
that's important and epictetus has some
good examples here he says if someone
brings you word that somebody's speaking
ill of you don't defend yourself against
them but answer
yes indeed they did not know the rest of
the faults that attached to me if they
had
this would not be the only one that they
had mentioned a great example right of
how to pick something up by the right
handle
um
it kind of you know makes you think
about the the situation it very often
disarms critics uh who are after you for
one reason or another in chapter 36 um
here's another nice one granted that for
you to take the larger share at dinner
is good for your body still it's bad for
the maintenance of the proper kind of
social feeling so when you're eating
with another person remember to regard
not merely the value for your body of
what lies before you one handle but to
maintain your respect for the host
another handle which one are you going
to pick up
you know if you pick up the one
sooner or later you're not going to have
any dinner parties because you're a jerk
and nobody wants to hang out with you
if you pick up the other handle even
though you don't get to eat as much as
you'd like of whatever it is that
they're serving
you get to hang out with other people
and here's another one that's very very
tough and again you know people often
get get you know quite upset when they
they hear this one i've got a whole
piece out there that you can easily find
about stoicism and relationships that
that discusses this passage
with everything that entertains you
is useful or of which you are fond or
feel affection towards remember to say
to yourself beginning with the very
least things what is its nature
if you're fond of a jug say i'm fond of
a jug for when it's broken you will not
be disturbed
if you kiss your own child or wife
say to yourself you're kissing a human
being for when it dies you will not be
disturbed now people hear that and
they're like oh those stoics are cold
and mean right
um
i mean
the word there for feel affection or
fond it already includes loving
philosophy right field of story again
so he's not saying don't feel affection
it's just remind yourself of the way
things actually are pick things up by
the right handle you know the wrong
handle is everybody that i love because
i love them is going to live forever and
everything's going to be awfully great
boy if you carry things by then handle
you're going to have a rough time
people die people get sick
people have misunderstandings that is a
handle by which you can carry something
because it's realistic
if you think about our workplaces right
our work conditions sometimes suck right
pay and possibilities for advancement
and and you can choose in a situation
like that what do you want to focus on
you don't have to pretend that your boss
is is good when they're not you don't
have to pretend that the pay is fair
when it's not but you can say to
yourself something like well
this affords me the opportunity to you
know provide for
myself or my family while i look for a
better job right or it could just be
well this is the best that i can find
but
this is indeed providing me with some
sort of income it's up to you how you
choose to focus on things
so let's take some uh we'll take
questions specifically on this one but
then we can also take some more general
questions about stoicism
as well
marco says connected to the topic of
currency being traded if you don't mind
what's the currency which epictetus
suggests you don't sell uh your dignity
uh your your prior races you know um
having to tell yourself that
things that are false are true
those those are things that epictetus
would say you probably you know you
don't want to sell those things and and
people do sell those things and you can
look at them and say are their lives
really happy or are they even though
they have like wealth and social
prestige are they still miserable
bastards you know who blow up at people
marco didn't epictetus praise socrates
and how he had endured abuse from his
wife sometimes i feel epictetus goes to
such extremes misinterpretation it
sometimes seems inevitable of common
sense isn't applied yeah so there's a
good good point there if you don't apply
common sense and you want to be
tendentious about it or you you know you
you want to misunderstand as i think a
lot of people do well then you'll
misunderstand
but again that's that's a choice that a
person makes right
and um you know
you you actually got to sympathize with
xanthepay
um when you look at socrates and how he
lived his life epictetus kind of
idolizes socrates i kind of think
socrates was a bad dad and a bad husband
and
you know sometimes picked the wrong
battles myself
you know when it comes to stoicism like
seneca says we don't have kings we don't
have to we don't have to buy every
single thing right
and
just because epictetus praises socrates
so much doesn't mean that we have to
think that socrates is as good as
epictetus hundreds and hundreds of years
later makes him out to be
corey says i wonder if the currency
might be our attention that's a currency
not the currency it's been said we most
dearly pay for anything if we pay too
much of our attention there's lots of
currencies right and so we decide which
things we want to exchange for which
things there is no one single
currency in this metaphor that that
epictetus is
using um
everett when you responded to marco's
question about currency what do you or
epictetus or stockdale mean by dignity
probably different things and epictetus
doesn't have a word for dignity so
i wouldn't worry about defining it so
much
i think that's that's something you know
substitute whatever word you want
integrity that could work too right
honesty
um
elliott less about the content i'm
wondering if there's a particular
translation you prefer for the encordian
i don't have preferred translations
because i can read greek
i actually did a whole video about this
a while back because people ask me so
much about which translation is the best
and my answer is i don't know because
i'm not a good
person to answer that question
the only reason i'm using the old father
is it's convenient
i mean obviously i dislike translations
that play too fast and loose
with things but you know most
translations are okay
and i don't expect that much out of them
and whenever something gets kind of
weird i just go to the original language
and i i'm fortunate in that i can do
that for
uh
for greek latin french and german
[Music]
can't do it for other languages then i
have to trust the translator and i don't
i don't know if you can trust the
translator like who's whose translation
of dostoyevsky or kierkegaard is the
best
i don't know because i can't check it
against the original so so i don't have
i don't have a good answer to
translation i have good answers to like
how should we translate x y or z given
this passage i don't have good answers
to
whose translations are the the best
translations
uh james there is some controversy in
modern stoicism about the degree if any
to which we are fingers on a bigger hand
yeah
my thoughts i think there isn't a
controversy in modern stoicism about
that um this is the first that i'm
hearing about that controversy and i'm
on the modern stoicism team so
if you mean uh questions like how
ontologically dependent are we on
you know groups and societies
that's an interesting question
the stoics very clearly think that we
have sort of a dual nature we we are
individuals but we are individuals who
exist within society right and we are
parts of larger holes
that seems
entirely uncontroversial because all the
all the major stoics say that
so i don't i don't see a lot of uh a
controversy about that
marco are we doing questions in general
yeah i said we could we could do
questions in general after we got
through all the practices so
um
[Music]
gary i wonder what a stoic would say to
someone who asserts excessive emotions
are part of human nature and as a
consequence in accordance with nature
they would say they're wrong
that's that's pretty straightforward you
know why would they say that they're
wrong well that's where we get into the
nitty-gritty and there is a really
really good book that i can recommend
if you want to get into understanding
the stoics on emotion
and that would be margaret graver's
stoicism and emotion really wonderful
book she does a great survey of all the
classic stoic
texts and thinkers
on these matters
you know
and here's where we can say listen there
are different conceptions of what human
nature is
and sometimes you got to pick one rather
than pick another you got to pick which
seems more reasonable to you
i mean
for me somebody who asserts that
excessive emotions are part of a fully
developed human nature
seem to me naive and off base
and i think the stoics are probably more
right i also think aristotle has a lot
of things right that maybe the stomachs
don't agree with but you know the idea
that that you know excessive human
emotions are i mean there's part being
part of human nature and being part of
like how us screwed up human beings
react to things sure the stoics have no
problem with saying that in the screwed
up state that most of us are in we have
excessive emotions is that what we want
is that desirable that's a whole
different question
uh marco how is virtue connected with
epictetus's concept of freedom
virtue freedom
you know they're they're connected with
each other
epictetus doesn't talk as much about the
virtues as say seneca does or marcus
aurelius
or cicero and his his summaries of what
the stoics say but it's there you know
and
you know if you want to be
free you've got to be virtuous and what
are the what are the virtues that the
stoics recognize um you know these big
four cardinal virtues which each have
their own sub virtues wisdom
temperance courage and justice you know
so if you want a happy free life you
have to
you have to figure out what those
virtues are and start practicing them
and developing them and if you don't
you're going to be you're going to be
unhappy
peter what are your thoughts on dr
irvine's trichotomy of control if we can
influence an outcome it would seem to me
the outcome is still not a given would
that still be outside of our control or
do i understand this incorrectly
you know you again i'll reference you to
something that i've written about i i've
got a piece out there specifically
considering this
um you know what does epictetus think is
what epictetus thinks is in our power
and i think that you know irvine is is
um
helpful in saying
yeah i mean there's lots of things where
we control the intention or the effort
and we don't control the outcome do we
have to set up a trichotomy
no because epictetus already talks about
those sort of cases
in the discourses as things where
they're externals and we use them the
greek word for that is crisis
and so i don't you know i don't think
that we need irvine's trichotomy of
control if we understand
um
epictetus sufficiently
um
atal how would you look at the
usefulness of emotions as a means to
judge a situation and what you
subconsciously think of something so
that you can react accordingly
yeah that's good work if you can get it
uh most people's emotions are not
sufficiently on point and have been you
know sort of
uh
messed up through you know all sorts of
misshapen desires and assumptions
so you know anger is a great example a
lot of people think that because they're
angry at something now they have the
right take on it and it can motivate
them to virtuous action and then they do
horrible things you know
emotions can be useful if they are you
know integrated well with rationality
that is rarely the case for for most
people uh but it's certainly something
that we can we can work on
courtney uh what do you think about the
stoics concern it's unwise to let
emotion
as opposed as opposed to some measure of
emotion as they carry us beyond what is
reasonable
i think that the stoics are pretty much
right about that and that plato and
aristotle and those traditions agree and
so actually so does the epicurean
um
everett correct me if i'm wrong but
epictetus talks a lot about keeping your
moral purpose regarding aversion and
desire what if i don't really know what
right or wrong as well the answer to
that is most of us don't know really
what right or wrong is we have some kind
of
mixed up conceptions of that but we can
improve them right
uh and if what if i don't believe that
anything is morally right or wrong well
good luck with that that way of living i
mean nobody nobody is truly a moral
relativist when you get down to it those
are very abstract worries
um that
you don't really see playing out in in
real life
uh gary can you tell us something about
the most important differences and
similarities between stoicism and the
philosophy of the 17th century dutch
philosopher spinoza
yes spinoza has this incredibly static
universe that's you know essentially
mechanistic
and
there's only one substance and that's
god and we're merely modes of it um
the stoics think that we actually do
have selves you know um
so
and you know spinoza's ethics
gets rid of a lot of things that that
stoics think are are important um i kind
of think that you know spinoza is a
overrated philosopher
uh and he's got kind of an aura about
him sort of like hegel you know with the
phenomenology a lot of people like
talking about
um you know hegel but don't really
understand them i think a lot of people
talk about spinoza but don't adequately
understand them because if they did
they'd be like yeah i don't want that
you know
um so
um
we're gonna have to wrap up in about
five minutes um
so i don't know if i'll get to
everybody's questions
marco says epictetus's works are full of
parables between the art of living and
other arts for example carpentry do you
have any favorite of his uh parables you
mean yeah i mean some of that i put in
here like you know picking things up by
the right handle i think that's a great
analogy right we've got two handles and
if you've ever like if you ever had to
move people right uh and you like
screwed up your back because you picked
up things the wrong way which i've done
in the past you learn this lesson about
picking things up in a way that you can
carry them you know i also remember as a
young man carrying um you know sheets of
drywall from the attic the fourth floor
attic all the way down to the to the
basement in our barracks in the army and
like doing it the right way where i
could carry massive amounts of stuff and
people like that's too much weight you
know and i'd be like nah man i can do it
i think that's a great great metaphor
there's all these wonderful metaphors we
do have to be a little bit careful right
when we're dealing with metaphors
not to
push them too far and say this is the
perfect account of everything we always
want to keep in mind what the metaphor
is
saying
uh
adam says marcus talks about dropping an
opinion how could that be so easy nobody
says it's easy
right so why are you reading in
marcus telling you that it's simply easy
uh
the stoics know that this is is
difficult to do you have to keep working
at it and working at it and get you know
who is marcus talking to himself he's
not talking to you you're just an extra
reader on the side we happen to have
benefited from uh marcus's work but he
was writing to himself sort of like
saying you dumb bastard why aren't you
fixing why aren't you fixing yourself
why do you keep making the same damn
mistakes over and over again right
um all right well let's we got a couple
minutes left let's see uh
welby how do the stoics react to
suffering especially in terms of
emotions abuse or torture
so there's there's two answers to give
how do they react to it directed towards
themselves
and how do they do how do they act when
it's directed towards somebody else like
for example what if i find out that my
child
is being bullied should i again
something else i've written about in
other places because these are common
questions that come up
should i say to them well you know the
stoics teach that we can all be free and
you know you don't worry about those
bullies they're not insulting you you're
it's only your judgment no no we don't
do that
we recognize injustice as injustice and
we try to oppose it and you notice
that's what the historical stoics
actually did oppose and criticize
and recognize that other people are not
stoics and we can also recognize that
about ourselves we can say i'm not the
stoic sage i probably will have some
trigger points that i gotta watch it i
can put up with this much abuse and and
you know recognize that the other person
they are acting like a jerk but they're
doing so because you know that's that's
the way they are brought up or they you
know they've got a bad character and
then at a certain point i can say okay
that's enough i'm
removing myself from the situation or
i'm opposing myself to you right that
that is something that it while you're
not a stoic sage and nobody's ever
nobody i know has ever met a stoic sage
um that's perfectly uh
okay to do i would say
um
atoll has another good one here would it
be appropriate to say that stoicism is
the solution to integrating rationality
with emotion or is there a different
branch of philosophy that focuses more
on it yes both um stoicism has a lot to
offer
there is also the platonic tradition
which includes plutarch who has a lot to
say about the emotions there's the
entire aristotelian tradition even the
epicureans as seneca recognizes have
some good stuff to say and those are
those are just an ancient philosophy
right then we could talk more broadly
about incorporating wisdom traditions
from other places than greece and rome
we can talk about moving ahead into the
middle ages and the early modern period
we don't have to
uh if we want to you know bring in
stoicism it doesn't mean that we can
only have stoicism any more than we
have to only be cartesians or hegelians
or things like that we can we can use
multiple
um things and and i think that that
makes for a stronger
way of working at things so people are
saying thanks um you know thanks to all
of you for showing up and helping me
test this new platform out which seems
to be a success it seems to have worked
seamlessly as far as i can tell
soros i think is still here uh and and
getting to see it working in action so
that that's awesome as well
and uh this this is being recorded so it
should show up on the
site for this so you can go back over it
if you want to and
now i'm gonna go spend some some time
with my oldest daughter before she goes
home
for the summer uh from being here at
university of wisconsin-milwaukee we're
going to hang out and do a few things
but i'm glad all of you could join me
for this
and i'm you know you're all very welcome
you